Speaker 1: Donald Trump is panicking and
switching into hoarse space mode, referring
to Stormy Daniels now exclusively as horse face.
He used to. First it was Stormy Daniels, then
it was Stormy Horse face Daniels. And now it is
just horse face in a global humiliation of Trump
panicking. I would say he's red in the face, but
because he's so orange, you can't tell about the
possibility that he may be indicted in connection
with the entire Stormy Daniels affair. And it's
an affair both in the sense that it is an incident
and it is a it is an affair also in the sense that
Trump had an affair with Stormy Daniels. Look at
this insanity that happened this morning and over
the last 24 hours with Donald Trump. This is a
man who is not well and he's arguably on the edge,
not only of major legal trouble, but he seems to
be close to a complete and total mental breakdown,
panicking and furious about everything, even
things he has misunderstood, which is really the
summary of modern Republicanism. We are furious
about things we either misheard, misinterpreted,
or flat out don't understand. Take a look at this.
Trump posting to Truth Social Censure. Quote I did
nothing wrong in the horse case. This is a former
president. I did nothing wrong in the horse race
case. I see. She showed up in New York today
trying to drum up some publicity for herself.
I haven't seen or spoken to her since I took a
picture with her on a golf course in full golf
gear, including a hat. Close to eight years ago.
I guess he's saying if he was wearing golf gear,
they couldn't possibly have engaged in sexual
intercourse. She knows nothing about me. Well,
she actually seems to know some intimate things
about Trump. She knows nothing about me other
than her con man lawyer. Avenatti misspelled and
convicted liar and felon jailbird Michael Cohen
may have schemed up, never had an affair with
her. Just another false acquisition by a Capital
S sleazebag. Witch hunt. I assume Trump means a
false accusation, but he called it an acquisition.
Can you imagine a guiltier sounding statement
than this? I was wearing so many clothes around
her that there's no way anything happened. And
also her face is a horse face. So she's not
attractive enough, I guess, for Trump to have had
an affair with her now. The other thing a couple
people emailed me about is to what degree is Trump
focusing on this term affair like in Trump's mind?
Maybe affair means something different than an
isolated sexual encounter. I don't know. I don't
know whether there was some kind of technicality
there. Trump continuing and then switching over to
his other obsession, Ron DeSantis saying, quote,
In addition to wanting to cut Social Security
and raise the minimum age to at least 70 and
Medicare Rhino Ronda Sanctimonious is delivering
the biggest insurance company bailout to globalist
insurance companies in history. He's also crushed
Florida homeowners whose houses were destroyed in
the capital H hurricane. They're getting pennies
on the dollar. His insurance commissioner does
nothing while Florida's lives are ruined. This is
the. Worst capital I insurance capital scam in the
entire capital C country. And then lastly, just
hours ago, turning caps lock on and completely off
the wall, posting quote, the fake investigations
by radical left Democrat prosecutors are nothing
other than election interference into the politics
of a failing nation. Maga. Now I want to try
to be really crystal clear here. It is okay
to acknowledge that there is a comedic element
here. When you hear Trump Trump a trunk, when
you hear Trump talk about Ron Desanctis and use
the term horse race in a serious manner and all
these things. There. I understand that there's a
76 year old man, sort of like screaming at clouds
with nicknames and insults. And he's he's dark
orange and he's sweating and he's mistaking words
and furious at whoever's running the teleprompter
like I. There's a hugely comedic element here.
But we also need to not allow the cartoonish
comedy of it to get in the way of remembering
that this man was president for four years. He
had access to the most sensitive information.
He had access, at least theoretically, to the
nuclear nuclear codes and could have launched
nuclear weapons. He was the head of state in
the sense of running foreign policy for a while,
even though he understood nothing. That's not
funny. And we don't want to let the humor of
it. And I agree, there's humor. It's okay to
recognize the humor of it. And sometimes we
recognize the humor so that we laugh instead
of cry. I get it. We don't want to let that.
Minimize the danger of this man in our minds. And
Sam Harris recently spoke about this. And whatever
you think about Sam Harris. Every once in a while,
Sam Harris has some extraordinarily prescient
points. Sam Harris spoke about this recently. We
can't let the humor get in the way of the fact
that this is crazy and dangerous. All caps, horse
face the Senate. There's all this difference.
Yeah, okay, I get it. But this is a very dangerous
person. And if he were to become president again,
it would potentially be disastrous for the
United States and for the world. We'll have
more on this on her Instagram search Instagram
for David Pakman show. You'll find plenty there.